foreign
[Music]
hey you guys welcome back to tomes of
Terror I know I haven't done one of
these in a couple of weeks but that's
just because I got behind on my reading
because of other things going on so
hopefully I'll be able to get back to
doing one of these a week like I was
before so this book right here I have to
admit that it was actually the title of
this one that initially caught my
attention uh there was something kind of
like vaguely mysterious and kind of like
ominous about it which I kind of liked
um I will also admit that it took me a
while to get through this book not
entirely because of the way it was
written because I did like I mentioned
have you know the holidays and other
work responsibilities and things like
that that kind of prevented me from
reading as much as I would normally like
or giving as much time to this book as I
would have liked but that was partially
the reason
and I'm also going to make a statement
right up front that if you're really not
into Slow Burn horror then this is
probably not the book for you this is
one of the slowest slow Burns I've ever
read and that's not necessarily A
criticism I'll kind of elaborate more on
that thought uh in a bit and matter of
fact this book actually kind of reads
more like a somber piece of literary
fiction uh for almost the entire
440 450 Pages something like that
um until it goes kind of like full-on I
guess like Cosmic horror sci-fi-ish like
toward the end now prior to that it's
all build up with a very very limited
set of characters
um that eventually gets whittled down to
our main protagonist and the main
antagonist how you feel about that is
kind of up to you um I was actually
intrigued enough by the rather languidly
unfolding mystery and also sympathetic
enough with the main character that I
stuck with it until the end but other
readers mileage may vary this seems like
it got like really really really really
great reviews or like people that were
just like boring couldn't finish it like
nothing happened stuff like that so I'm
just like giving you a warning right out
the gate like if you don't like Slow
Burn horror then probably this isn't the
book for you so the author Troy Aaron
Ratliff is uh apparently an Ohio native
and he was evidently best known for his
short stories prior to the release of
this novel which if I didn't mention it
before was called do I bother you at
night and this came out in 2013. uh so
this was his first full-length novel in
the notes at the end he actually says
that he got the idea for this story like
back when he was 17 and he had grown up
I guess like on his parents farm and he
kept seeing like he I guess it made a
big impression on him when he saw this
like kind of eerie blue Arc Light like
coming from his neighbor's barn like as
the neighbor kids were like working on
their motorbikes and stuff like that and
he was like thinking how Eerie it was
like seeing that across the Prairie or
whatever and I will say that ratliff's
prose is very wordy but it's actually
like really really evocative and his
descriptions of like the characters and
the settings and stuff like that really
kind of like immersed me into the world
uh because of its kind of like rural
very small town Vibe it it gave me kind
of like a little bit of a whiff of maybe
like Thomas tryons and like like Harvest
home or something like that or maybe
like a Midwestern version of Stephen
King so at the beginning of the story
there's kind of like this really brief
prologue which seems to be a transcript
of like an interview or something like
that between two like military guys I
guess like in a superior like
interviewing like an inferior officer or
whatever and they're kind of discussing
obliquely the absconding of a third
person and a dangerous device that he
might have in his possession
so then we jump into the main narrative
which is actually set in 1986 but
occasionally jumps back in time to like
the 1970s so there are like a few
flashbacks like peppered in here and
there but it mostly takes place in 1986.
so the story focuses on a farmer named
Sylvester Peterson and he lives alone on
just acres and Acres of cornfield in a
very very rural part of Kansas
um he's in his late 30s I think they say
and he's kind of something of a loner uh
especially since the very horrific
suicide of his you know much beloved
wife sometime before like he gets up and
he does his routine every day he working
on his farm he lives very very quietly
um but you can tell like he's stoically
grieving you know what I mean but he's
not kind of one of those like I said
he's a very very stoic like Midwestern
type of dude where they kind of like
keep all of their emotions bottled up
like on the inside so you can seem like
you see that he's very much like that
um he also seems like something of an
introvert uh which you know I could
totally relate to you and also kind of
like a creature of habit so this is
established like pretty thoroughly like
throughout the first segments of the
book which basically kind of like just
follows him throughout his days kind of
delving into his thoughts and memories
just like as he goes about his regular
routine now pretty much the only social
outlet I guess that Sylvester has is
occasionally having his best friend
Dustin over
um he comes over to like drink beers and
watch the Kansas City Royals like
whenever they're playing like on TV
Dustin I think is like a little bit
older than Sylvester like in his early
40s maybe and he's really into like
horror movies and like weird X-Files
[ __ ] like inspiratorial stuff
um but Sylvester is kind of like a more
pragmatic no-nonsense down to earth type
of guy but despite I mean but despite
their differences though they have like
a very solid friendship although it's
like not very deep like I said they
don't really like share a lot of
emotions or anything it's mostly like
you know kind of like a guy kind of
friendship from the Midwest you know
what I'm saying so the only other people
that Sylvester sees with any frequency
are Willie who's like this kindly old
man who's kind of like a father figure
to him and he owns the General Store
like it's a general store an electronic
store in town and a guy named Ethan who
seems mostly okay until like part way
during the story he does something like
really really shitty uh that causes
Sylvester to pretty much like cut ties
with him for the rest of the story and
really the only other kind of major
characters that is Reggie and he's like
kind of like a nice high school kid or
he's like a College Bound kid who helps
out on the farm in the Summers now since
the death of his wife
um you know all of Sylvester's friends
are a little bit worried about him
because they think that he's kind of
become a little bit reclusive like more
reclusive than normal it's kind of
implied that he was sort of like that
before but it's kind of gotten worse
since his wife died and as The Story
Goes On uh they also start to suspect
that he might be very slowly losing his
marbles but I'm kind of getting ahead of
myself a little bit see Sylvester lives
pretty far out on the edge of this like
tiny ass town and his nearest neighbor
is is kind of like way across the corn
fields like where because it's all flat
like he can see it but it's like pretty
far away you know what I mean maybe like
a half mile or a mile or something like
that but he can still kind of see it now
the guy who used to live next door which
like I said way the hell over there was
actually friends with Sylvester at one
point but the two men kind of at some
point in the past like before the events
of the book had a falling out about like
property lines or something and
Sylvester just kind of like wrote him
off so he didn't even realize that the
guy had moved away at some point like
months and months ago very very
gradually though it starts to become
clear that somebody else has moved into
The Farmhouse like across away from
Sylvester's really kind of the first
inkling that something is different is
that at first he kind of just sees and
hears this very Sleek like newer
Cadillac periodically kind of roaring
down this Rural Road where he lives and
like I said nobody else lives down there
and he knows like all the cars out in
this neck of the woods and this is not
one of them and then on the very rare
occasions that he Ventures into town
like to get supplies or whatever the all
the other residents are just like asking
about this new very mysterious neighbor
that Sylvester has now Sylvester has has
not seen him at this point like he's
just seen his car every now and then but
apparently a lot of other folks have
seen him although all they can really
tell him is that the dude looks like
he's from the city like he's not from
around there uh he kind of uh
occasionally smells like sulfur and
sometimes buys kind of like strange
electronic gadgets like from Willie's
store
so at some stage like the townsfolk
learned that the guy's name is Calvin
but so far like Sylvester has actually
like yet to see him even though he's the
one that lives closest to the guy So
eventually Sylvester starts getting a
little bit irritated that every time he
goes into town like that's all that the
residents seem to ask him about
um is hey have you seen that guy like
what's his deal or whatever and they're
all like really incredulous when he
tells him that he still hasn't seen him
but you know it's like Sylvester doesn't
really have time for all of this gossipy
[ __ ] I mean he just wants to kind of
keep his head down and get on with his
very simple life which is also kind of
like like I said very isolated and kind
of empty in a way but it seems like
satisfactory to him but then he has to
admit that he's also starting to get a
little bit curious as to what Calvin
might be up to over there Sylvester kind
of starts to notice this blue glow like
emanating from the dude's Barn like from
time to time and even more alarmingly uh
Sylvester sometimes sees something
moving around found in his cornfield
like out the windows at night and stuff
like that and he can't really like tell
what it is there are also these kind of
strange like perfectly round depressions
in the earth like of different sizes
that sometimes manifest like at random
spots like in the cornfield
um and also there's these kind of
infrequent but really really terrifying
like screeching sounds that kind of like
blare out of the Corn that are like
insectile sounding that he's never heard
before
there's also kind of like this really
thin like kind of raggedy looking golden
retriever who looks like a stray but he
just kind of like wanders into the Rose
from time to time and he seems to be
getting like fatter and fatter like
every time Sylvester sees him now at one
stage uh you know quite a ways into the
book Sylvester actually meets Calvin at
Willy's store in town and the man isn't
like overtly bizarre or anything like
he's not a monster or a vampire or
nothing like that but he is a little bit
odd and you know like I said he's
definitely definitely not from around
there now after this encounter which is
not overtly Sinister but like a little
bit weird like the [ __ ] that the guy
says
um Sylvester starts getting more and
more preoccupied with the guy and he
decides as the story goes on that he is
absolutely going to find out what
exactly that dude is doing like over at
that Farmhouse over there but the thing
about it is that is the guy really up to
like some weird nefarious [ __ ] or is
Sylvester just kind of like succumbing
to paranoia or succumbing to his grief
which he hasn't really examined to any
great extent and maybe he's having like
a mental breakdown you know what I mean
so as I mentioned uh do I bother you at
night is a very leisurely paced story
like to put it mildly but I'm gonna say
though that it very much mirrors the
very laconic like unhurried existence of
Sylvester like the main protagonist it's
almost kind of like paced the same way
that his life is you know what I mean
which I actually kind of liked I liked
that mirroring effect so for the bulk of
the novel we're basically just going
along with Sylvester as he you know just
does just lives his life you know he's
just like puttering around the house or
working around his farm hanging out with
Dustin or making kind of like grudging
Journeys into town to like stock up and
it's like thinking about how he doesn't
really want to do it because like I said
he's really introverted now as the
Intrigue surrounding Calvin like his
neighbor kind of deepens more and more
were immersed more into Sylvester's head
and his life's kind of slowly starts to
become more isolated more obsessive and
all of his former contacts and Friends
kind of just like start falling by the
wayside like one by one so in many ways
it's a very
um intimate like a very inner directed
tale I guess and I will say that it's
actually a good thing that Sylvester is
such a likable uh character like one
that you really really empathize with
because I'm not sure that the structure
of the novel would have worked otherwise
like with a different kind of character
that wasn't um as likable as Sylvester
is now while there are occasional
flashbacks to Sylvester's former happy
life with his now deceased wife and some
of those flashbacks are actually from
her point of view because of like
something that happened to her in the
past almost all of the narrative is seen
through Sylvester's very limited point
of view so you're seeing everything from
like his Farmhouse as he's watching
things unfold like across the field now
I was actually quite enchanted with
Sylvester's character and this Enigma
that's like developing across the field
but I can also see how some readers
might just find the whole thing like
really boring because it does actually
quite take quite a long time for
anything
substantial to happen you know what I'm
saying the build up is actually like
very very subtle
um and it starts out with just seemingly
insignificant but like odd little
details and then those details are very
very slowly like kind of repeated or
expanded upon like they're getting worse
and worse and then the story just goes
like balls to the wall like in the last
I don't know like 50 pages or something
like that now I didn't mind this too
much
um although one one slight criticism I
would have liked I think for the other
handful of characters uh particularly
Dustin and Willie like both of whom I
really liked two have kind of like
factored more into the sort of climax or
you know into the Final Act
um as it was I kind of felt like all the
characters sort of like dissolved from
the story like as Sylvester started
closing himself away in his own house
like just watching his neighbor all the
time obsessively now although this
framework the way the novel is laid out
does kind of like match the mental state
of the of Sylvester obviously
I think I would have liked maybe just
maybe like a short epilogue to kind of
like mirror the prologue at the
beginning that detailed the aftermath of
this like Monumental incident that took
place at the end I mean I would have
liked to see how the rest of the
characters were affected by what happens
like in other words so I have to say
ratliff's writing um it really does
paint a picture in your mind like I
could totally see uh these kind of
waving lonely rows of corn like under
this big dome of sky with all the stars
and everything like that and I could
totally understand the kind of
creepiness of that whole like Placid you
know Norman Rockwell like Midwestern
kind of setting being disrupted by these
kind of like inexplicable like Sinister
doings like across the field you know
what I mean so in that sense the story
like really drew me in in spite of its
very very langerous Pace you know as far
as it go there were like a smattering of
grammatical errors but I mean barely
enough to mention I mean I've read ones
that were like wait way worse than this
one I think it was maybe like four or
five that I noticed it was like really
not a big deal at all
um and you know I'm gonna say on the
whole this was actually very very well
written although as I said it reads A
like very very descriptive it reads more
like literary fiction like very
descriptive literary fiction and it's
kind of like internal but it's still
like straightforward it's not obtuse or
anything like that or you know
complicated for the sake of being
complicated like you know it's easy to
know what's going on but a lot of it is
because the main character is so
introverted like a lot of it is kind of
like his inner dialogue or his kind of
like remembrances or things like that
like as the thing is going on so it's
more focused on that and less action
oriented at least until like you get to
the end so I mean if literary fiction
like that isn't really your bag and you
just want something that's kind of like
fast-paced and exciting then this book
is not it and you will probably not like
it on the other hand
um if you're kind of more into like
maybe some more like understated or more
like Insidious type of horror that kind
of just lures you in with this very
appealing character and then slowly
slowly like amps up the weirdness like
over the course of a few hundred Pages
until just this big explosion of like
what the [ __ ] like all at the end
like it literally like in the last 50
pages or so then you might just dig this
um it did take me a while to get through
like I said not entirely because of How
It Was Written but partly
um but I'm actually glad that I did
stick it out like until the end because
I ended up like really enjoying it in
the aggregate so this is uh if you have
Kindle unlimited this is available to
read for free on there at least as of
this recording so if it sounds like
something that you would be into then
check it out or if you've read it let me
know what you thought about it in the
comments and that will do it for this
tomes of Terror I'll see you guys again
on the next one bye
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign